the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
and A Song of Ice and Fire update video
in this video I will reveal the one
thing writers and showrunners David
benof and Dan way said they wish they
done differently while making Game of
Thrones that's right Dan and Dave
Finally Revealed what they consider to
be their biggest regret and their answer
might shock you because it doesn't have
anything to do with the final season of
the show now for those of you who don't
know Game of Thrones writers and
creators David Ben off and Dan Weiss
recently sat down for an interview where
they discussed their new Netflix series
in this new interview they also Finally
Revealed how they felt about the fans
reaction to the final season I went over
all that in my last video you should
watch that as well well if you haven't
already now I have to show you what they
said when they actually revealed what
they would have done differently if they
could I think most of us would assume it
has something to do with the last season
whether it's fixing Danny Jamie the
night king or one of the many other
things fans hated about how the show
ended well believe it or not it's
actually something from the very first
season a season I consider to be already
Flawless on my dad now before I show you
what they said there's some other
exciting new information I want to give
you right away winter is the perfect
time to Cozy up at home with a mobile
game that you can really get sucked into
I've been playing this amazing game with
Gorgeous gameplay that's available on
both mobile and PC not only that but you
can also seamlessly switch between
devices playing on them alternately I
also have to let you know about some
very exciting news the worlds of Rage
Shadow Legends and Monster Hunter are
colliding in an amazing limited time
crossover starting on January 9th 2024
and finishing on March 5th players can
collect five Monster Hunter them theme
Legendary Champions who are based on
iconic monsters from capcom's action RPG
franchise there's Rathalos zogre elreon
Fatalis and Ruiner Nar jante everyone
can get the Rathalos blademaster
legendary champion for free simply by
logging into raid for 7even days between
now and March 5th not only that but raid
Shadow Legends is also increasing its
roster of awesome looking Champions by
adding in brand new mythical Champions
these new mythical Champions have a
special new mechanic called
metamorphosis allowing them to change
between two different forms I mean
what's better than one Champion two
Champions right now imagine a single
Champion that was technically two
Champions a very powerful Warrior able
to change between two forms each with
their own set of unique skills raid's
brand new mythical Champion Rarities are
exactly that they switch between two
forms using their unique metamorphosis
skill and each form has a different type
so one could be a damage dealing Knight
and the other could be a flaming angel
of healing a mythical Champion's two
forms both use the same artifacts
accessories masteries and blessings so
be careful when you're choosing how to
use them these mythical Champions are
the most versatile champions ever seen
in raid with all of this exciting stuff
and more coming to raid if you haven't
started playing yet what are you waiting
for all you have to do is click my link
in the description or scan my QR code to
get insane bonuses available only via my
link now once you're in the game use the
promo code raid xmiss for both new and
old players after that come find me
under the name wildling Raider and join
my clan and don't forget to use my RAID
Shadow Legends Link in the description
or scan my QR code to get insane bonuses
for new players with an epic Champion
you don't want to miss out on this
amazing offer once again I have to thank
raid Shadow Legends for sponsoring
today's
video now let's have another look at Dan
and Dave's interview although they did
their best at avoiding any sort of
actual reflecting on Game of Thrones and
how it ended the writers did reveal one
thing they wish they could do over they
said remember more the Jailer he was
that thuggish guard in the sky cells at
the Eerie who was watching over lord
tirion Lannister now if you remember all
the way back in the first season L
Tyrion offers him a bribe to help him
escape and later gives him a sack of
gold coins because A Lannister Always
Pays his debts well Dan and Dave said
one thing I know we wish we could have
done is there's the character more the
Jailer it was a mistake not bringing
more the Jailer back into the series we
always talked about doing it and we even
had a scene for it Ben off says there's
a scene set in a Tavern was it Brienne
or the Hound why says but then we
realized too late that mord could have
owned that Tavern we could have had that
actor in the background acting exactly
the way he did as the Jailer except now
as a small business owner it was such an
obvious no-brainer day after idea it
seems like they basically wanted to do
this so us fans could go hey I remember
that guy that was more the Jailer from
the first season wow that's such an
awesome call back to the beginning of
the show I always wondered what happened
to that guy now I got to be honest here
my friends this might be the dumbest
answer they could have given what you
just said is one of the most insanely
idiotic things I have ever heard at no
point in your rambling incoherent
response were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought everyone in this room is now
Dumber for having listened to it I I
award you no points and may God have
mercy on your soul this feels like
another slap in the face to all the
millions of fans I mean seriously out of
everything that happened or could have
happened over the eight seasons of the
show this is the one thing they wish
they' done differently now I will admit
I wasn't expecting them to highlight any
of their massive failures from the final
season as much as I wish they would
acknowledge their mistakes from the
ending deep down I knew they wouldn't
they want to forget that season ever
happened how however there are so many
things they could have said how about
you fix your on greyjoy's entire
character I have an idea how about Howen
Reed actually shows up before the show
is over George R Martin has always said
we will see him before the story's over
and do I even need to mention what
happened with Dorne how about adding
another scene that adds more layers to
Littlefinger and varys's relationship
how about adding another scene with Jack
and AAR why not reveal more information
about the night king and the white
walkers why not reveal what ver H in the
Flames hell they could have even said
They wish they would have redone the
scene of Daenerys and drugo during their
wedding night they could have added the
conversation about tyrion's wife or fix
that awful scene that happened during
sansa's wedding night maybe they could
even admit one of their mistakes from
season 7 if they want to avoid
mentioning anything from the final
season for example they could have
redone the entire episode where Jon and
his friends went out Beyond the Wall to
capture a white everything that happened
in that episode was dumb from Gendry
running to Sans and arus fighting to the
night King killing viserion and even
Uncle benjin's Dex mcka just to have him
finally erase from the show let's not
even get into the hundreds of smaller
story lines they abandoned over the
years I have another idea let's go back
and fix Stannis and that embarrassing
battle at Winterfell I mean this list
could go on for hours again I know
they're scared to death to mention the
dumpster fire that happened in the final
season but there's so many other things
they could have fixed or done
differently that first season should be
one of the last seasons they're even
thinking about for some reason they
think these little callbacks to the
first season have more significance than
the actual story at hand now I do
realize I might be making something out
of nothing here but I honestly feel like
it's another slap in the face I bet they
thought it was funny to mention
something so insignificant when they
know damn well they made so many other
mistakes it annoys me how they always
want to avoid reflecting on the show I'm
not making that up either the
interviewer and author of the article
actually says that very thing it says as
the cover story notes and General they
staunchly avoid reflecting on the series
for whatever reason they no longer want
to discuss the one thing they're known
for I mean it's only the biggest show
ever created yet the mere mention of
Game of Thrones makes them Shiver I
understand they now work for Netflix and
they're wanting to talk about their new
show but the way they handled their exit
from Game of Thrones and even HBO as a
whole is insulting I'm actually grateful
they decided to leave a song of ice and
fires universe alog together if you saw
my last video or read this new article
then you know HBO wanted to keep Dan and
Dave attached to any and all future Game
of Thrones shows were kind of lucky that
never happened because they obviously
lost all love or interest for this story
it is a shame that it had to end this
way thankfully George rart now has Ryan
Condell working at his side someone who
actually knows and loves his writing one
day if George armar never decides to
finish writing a song of ice and fire I
hope HBO is able to Faithfully remake
the entire Game of Thrones series I
would absolutely love to see a word for
word at adaptation unfortunately however
it might be a while before we ever see
something like that happen at least we
will have House of the dragon and Duncan
egg to hold us over until then let me
know what all of you thought about this
new interview what are your thoughts
about Dan and Dave's answer do you like
their idea for more of the Jailer or do
you also think they should have focused
on fixing or adding something else leave
all your thoughts and answers down below
as always I have to thank all of you for
watching another video I also want to
thank raid for sponsoring this video
don't forget you can find that link down
below or scan the QR code so you can
enjoy their bonuses and join me in the
game right now once again have a great
day everyone I will see you again very
soon
[Music]
bye